Rahim most hurt the Niners running back
he had 58 yards on 12 carries and a
touchdown as the Niners of course losing
the Superbowl but Rahim kind enough to
join us how do you feel today we're him
no but hey it's a game we play you know
when you woke up this morning what's the
first thing you thought of first thing I
thought was yeah you know how do we end
up losing the game and you know what
what got done better in my due diligence
and trying to help the team you know um
get the W what was that feeling like to
score touchdown oh it felt great um I
felt like you know how I was in the
moment and I was enjoying it um you know
with my teammates and I did it for
everyone that uh you know believed in me
and didn't believe in me and yeah it was
one of those things where it was a it
was a childhood dream of mine and I
actually accomplished it did you keep
the football oh yeah okay explain to me
the logic on you know late in the game
if you get five yards on first down and
then Garoppolo throws two passes was
there any thought to just running the
football to taking up some clock and
maybe making them use a timeout there I
I was really surprised because you were
fresh yet and had that many carries and
I don't know what you were thinking at
that time yeah you know at the time you
just you hear a play call and you just
you know you try to overcome the
situation or whatever whatever the case
might be and it was really great play
call and by a coach Carson and um but
yeah it was one of those things where
you know like you say keep fresh and
almost I was fresh and ready to go um
but I'm more of a team guy you know I
whenever there's a play called or
somebody needs me to do something I'm
just going to be the first one to do it
um and that's that's basically how the
whole team is so um it was like you said
it was one of those things where we just
situation you know Kyle he's a great he
has a great mind a situational awesome
um you can't take that away from and he
knows that so you know is for us players
we just gotta go out there and execute
what was the locker room like after the
game you know same feeling how I had
this morning distraught couldn't believe
it you know we had it we had the win in
our in our grass all those things but um
you know we just we didn't get it done
and and you know we're proud of
ourselves the way we handled last year
and coming into this year and our
mentality and not my set um you know
wanting to be one of the best teams in
the league um you know trying to be one
of the best teams in in NFL history that
was our mindset from the start and we
accomplished that you know um is whether
the statistics prove it or not deep down
in our hearts we know that or one of the
greatest teams you know to play in the
Super Bowl
so he said rahim most heard the Niners
running back undrafted out of Purdue and
I saw where Damian Williams tracked you
down to trade jerseys What did he say to
you
you know you came up to me I didn't want
to I don't want to shake hands with
everybody just because like I said at
the moment I worked so hard to get to
where I'm at in life and to get to the
big stage and for us to lose it you know
it took a lot out of me um but yeah I
wanted to get off the field before
compared under that confetti was
supposed to be you know the the red and
gold confetti about the ready yellow um
so yeah for me it was one of those
things where I just had to go ahead and
just get off the field and bottle up my
emotions and just wait so I got a locker
he just he chased me down um you know he
came from all the way from their
sideline and chased me down in our
tunnel and you know he talked to me
I'm so damn proud of you because you
know we went we went through some things
when we were in Miami together and um
and he knows that and and and I know
that so for him to come up to me and
tell me you know he's proud of me and
stuff like that and I heard you earlier
you said you know you thought a person
somebody should somebody else should
have been MVP you know hot thoughts
about that oh then you played a heck of
a game we should have been MVP Rahim I
thought that he was the constant there
he had he played four good quarters
where mahomes is wonderful but he played
eight great minutes Damian was dating I
thought he should have been in the MVP
yeah he should have in my opinion I
definitely agree with that statement
simply because I got was catching the
ball out of the backfield when when
there was nothing to be you know there
was no throwing lane for cranny of the
receivers and and pat peddling a
wholesome yeah like I said he was outlet
form and he made chump place and did his
job thoroughly and executed his game
plan yeah but that caught man it was one
of those moments for me where you know
well I mean I'm gonna appreciate this
because um he is my brother and I text
him right after the game and he
responded way back right right away and
told me any look you know I'm so damn
proud yeah I said that
Congrats on the win and um enjoy it you
know with brothers for life and he said
for life you know that's just type of
bond that we have um you know we've
known each other for five years now and
and we always taught and you know
preseason and regular-season we've been
playing constantly so well congrats it's
a great story and you certainly paid
your dues there with the other teams
that you were with and hopefully you
found a home there with the Niners and
they should have used you a little bit
more last night but Congrats Raheem
you're a class act for calling in
hey I appreciate it don't thank for
having me man and hey you know we didn't
we didn't get the win but you know I
just want to let everyone know I'm proud
of part of this team and this
organization and
no Linda I want have done this without
without the guys in that locker room man
and we believe in each other so thank
you for having me I appreciate it it's
rahim most heard the Niners running back
12 carries 58 yards had a touchdown for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]